[Music]
all right so everybody in this room
except for nadine how much do we like
bacon
ew i [ __ ] hate bacon except for nicki
too i
always hated bacon milk now i don't want
to eat meat
i don't like the taste of it the smell
of it the smell of it actually the smell
of it reminds me of family now oh
because like my family would cook it
it's a pleasant smell but you like it
but i don't like eating is it too
processed
no like this that i don't like the meat
taste of it in fact like if it was
touching anything like if someone put
bacon on my eggs or something and then
they took it off i could still taste the
bacon is it specifically bacon or is it
pork belly uh
bacon sausage pepperoni any of you you
find one
belly that's pork chops oh yeah all the
pork i didn't even know as a kid that
they were all the same animal i just
hated all of those meats
i mean you're okay with pork belly
though like korean barbecue
no the only pork the only pork that i
liked was pulled pork
in hawaii that was the only pork that i
did
i didn't grow up eating bacon but i my
first taste of bacon
was a sleepover at my friend's house i
woke up in the morning and i was like
what the [ __ ] is this
and i just kept eating it it was good
mom was like you want more
you want more and she's she was so
surprised like what the [ __ ] is this you
never had bacon there in this
this woman was like all right my mom
told me she
she was embarrassed at as how much i
would eat
at other people's houses because i just
wasn't
used to like the food that they had so i
went nuts right because you didn't grow
with pork right no or like it's weird
because i agree with pork yeah my mom
made
everything was like pork and it was so
delicious and beef was rare and then
for you it was like beef was the only
thing you ate beef and
turkey bacon or whatever and then well
turkey bacon is because i begged my mom
to make that for me
and then she made turkey bacon and i was
like it ain't the [ __ ] safe oh see
i don't even like turkey bacon because
it tastes too much like regular really
uh maybe they add the hickory smell okay
yeah i don't like it i hate that you to
add your own curls to it
i [ __ ] mean when you cook turkey
bacon it's just flat and you have to add
your own little
you have to like squish it to make it
like i love bacon i'm i was like joe
where um
so my mom's vegetarian so i grew up with
a lot of like zero meat
and then i slept over at a friend's
house and then i was a filipino friend
and then i woke up in the morning and
i'm like what the [ __ ] is that smell
yeah that
morning bacon smell it just smelled so
good
add a sense of uh coffee being brewed
yeah
it's like heaven too that reminds me of
family all we ate was uh like rice
bacon and then you know that like
filipino sweet like banana sauce or
something
bit out of ketchup yeah yeah yeah banana
ketchup that's all we ate and it was
so good oh long anisa do you do you like
lionisa you're filipino
do you like a lot of nieces i don't
think i've tried that oh my goodness did
you get the sausage then
she doesn't even like sausages i don't
like sausage sausage yeah
no i don't like chorizo because like i
couldn't eat i couldn't eat pork so
but i've had it on accident like i
didn't know what it was all right so
when i've had like on pizza and i didn't
know i was like what the [ __ ]
is this like it didn't taste good and i
grew up on uh like a pepperoni
i grew up on beef pepperoni oh beef
pepperoni because he ate like pork
pepperoni on accident
you might as well eat tofu then nude
beef pepperoni is so [ __ ] good what
do you even get this
uh my uncle had a pizza shop and it was
all like food so they didn't have any
pork at the pizza was it like halal
pizza guy yeah i remember because i used
to work there too and i had this lady
come back and throw the pizza
she threw it at you guys she ordered
bacon but we didn't have we don't
we we say it's bacon but it's turkey
bacon
but did you guys also advertise
yourselves as being the halal yeah yeah
then you should [ __ ] know [ __ ]
exactly it's like when people go to
vegan places and they order chicken
and it's like fake chicken it's like
seitan chicken and they're like that
doesn't check it like it's a [ __ ]
vegan place
i would have gotten mad but yeah so all
this talk about pork and uh
bacon we can say goodbye to
a [ __ ] ton of bacon now because 10
million pigs are now
about to be euthanized do they got the
corona
no it's just no one's ordering [ __ ]
bacon anymore
restaurants are closed so 70 of all
bacon
is consumed at restaurants so it's just
a waste
so now they're just killing the pigs but
no one's eating them yeah they're so
they're
so sad for pork right now and so then
all the
pork farmers are like we have like
[ __ ] grown-ass pigs that need to be
processed at this point and we can't
keep feeding them because we have yeah
let them hang out in the field well
they're gonna die a terrible death that
way because if you let him
let him go then things will come after
them eat them you know i think you're
going to let them loose
let somebody else eat them
being euthanized is like i don't know
how they get euthanized i actually agree
with that one's more humane but
especially if they were never in the
wild they won't know how to fend for
they try to do
this and they fly here pigs can survive
anywhere
yeah they will that's where we have our
boards well they stop
then after they euthanize them will they
stop breeding them
i don't think because that's the problem
they're prepping for the next wave
of hopefully improvement in the economy
and
demand for pork supplies and they'll
start breeding them again
no they're they're already breeding
they're they're the little pigs
they're so smart they're the one animal
there that i'm like oh they're like
dogs they like remember people they're
very smart they can read but they taste
good though
you look at a pig's eyes they look like
people yeah they do
also cow eyes and it's like grandpa skin
eyes
of many animals it's like fat grandpa
look they just look like
human eyes they have look at that fat
grandpa look it's crazy and
they actually have the emotional
intelligence of a five-year-old
and they can you can teach pigs how to
read too don't tell me it is i love pork
and they're very smart they're smarter
than dogs
steve was just telling us about how he
can't really eat pork anymore because
you keep telling him about how smart
they commit suicide sometimes
in there because they're because they
get separated from their moms and they
like
what do they do to do that they ram
their heads against the wall until they
die
are you sure he's not like that one
chinese guy who's trying to strengthen
his forehead
she wasn't here for that article
but yeah so the pork industry they say
is uh in a year it's about 20 billion
worth wow and then this move right here
they're projected to lose about five
billion of that wow
a quarter of the [ __ ] industry well
can't they just like do things to
preserve it or like
freeze them or something like they don't
have the infrastructure for it like you
hear about
that's like oil that's like what's
happening with that and that's why the
oil prices crash and milk
have you guys seen the farmers dumping
tons of [ __ ] milk so
the the issue i remember uh reading
about the potato farmer in ireland you
know they
they make a lot of potatoes over there
right and the problem
is that uh this farmer i think 80
percent of his crop
goes to restaurants only so they don't
go they can't go to grocery stores
because he can't individually package
them like people normally buy them in
the truckloads right yeah
so to be able to package them
individually and then sell them
it would go bad by then yeah so then
what he decided to do which was really
dope
was that he just posted on facebook was
like hey free potatoes
come and then people came from all
around the country with like
just their trunks they opened it and
they filled it well oh my gosh
that's cool but i guess you can't do
that for here because i mean did he
[ __ ] read pigs
yeah because i mean seriously the
problem with the grocery stores didn't
have potatoes like the grocery stores
were low
but there was no infrastructure to get
it they all have their own different
pipelines like these guys
go to restaurants these guys go to
grocery stores and that's all they do i
think the people that are on the outside
they think why don't you just do this
because
the solution isn't that simple you can't
just mix systems together yeah that's
kind of like how
we had to deal with the masks yeah like
the supply chain
for the masks that specifically went to
hospitals were all dried up but the ones
that were going to retailers were still
there so we were able to be in the
middle
and grab these up and send it to the
hospitals
but that's kind of like the same thing
um i have a buddy who owns a farm and he
was saying how like
the margins are so [ __ ] low for
farmers and that's why they
survive off something called subsidies
which is government funded this is
something that kind of happened during
the great depression where
um farms were producing food but they
couldn't get it
to the cities and all that and then to
keep them operating
the government started giving them money
for it and all that so a lot of farms
today like you see them and you see
huge operations and you think they're
making money but they're barely scraping
by it's crazy
it kind of sucks that i think just just
when lives are involved because if they
if it's like farmer throws away
10 000 carrots no one gives a [ __ ] i
wonder what would happen if you did the
same facebook post come get your pig
yeah would people just pick i would be
worried about lawsuits because what if
the pig is sick and people get sick
yeah there's just so many things i
always wanted a pet pig
i know they're so cute and they love you
and there's already places in texas with
a hella pig event stations like the
places where you can
rent a helicopter and mow them down with
a like a machine gun it's because
there's already way too many pigs over
there and wouldn't it [ __ ] up the
industry
if people get free pigs and then there's
15 billion more pigs like in circulation
or like 15 billion more sales that could
happen but then it also eats into the
profit because he floods the market with
free pigs
i don't think people are slaughtered
yeah i don't think people are going to
be slaughtering yeah
really okay because i when i heard free
pigs i'm like
free me imagine feeding one pig that's a
lot of money and then
if even if you decide to eat it like
that's not going to destroy the market
of just one
one people you can run out pretty quick
it's like one week's worth of food
most people even know how to sell their
own pig yeah true
plus it's like i don't think you could
just take a pig from a farm and turn
that into a pet
as can you i
yeah and a lot of meat processing plants
are closing down too
like several yeah the meat prices are
going up like
every time i go to a grocery store i'm
like looking at the meat so i'm like you
can see it going every cent every cent
yeah the other one's like 20 cents a
little more expensive this time
30 cents and more expensive i wish my
fridge was bigger i'm trying to save
some meat i know
the vegans are winning wendy's don't got
meat now
that sucks wendy's yeah because you know
wendy's their their thing is always
we got fresh meat with the fresh patties
but because they get
meat delivered every day we're low on
meat now they just don't have any beef
so you can only buy chicken there you
know beyond meat stock is going up
have you had impossible meat impossible
burgers
why the [ __ ] you lying like no they have
at the grocery stores now it's cool
i just tweeted it because it's so good
why you always lying
it's really good if you like especially
if you have your own right
they sell it not even as patty they sell
it as just ground meat you can make it
as anything that's dope you cannot
tell the difference
i guarantee wait what is it yeah cause
that's the one gripe i have with beyond
meat burgers is like
there's kind of there's like a little
there's like a little weird taste there
it depends on who cooks it impossible
like caramelizes and everything
oh there's a difference yeah what is it
is one actually
meat but like pro like it's all vegan
it's it's all
plant-based and then they use this uh
impossible burger has
heme in it right like so the same the
chemical that's in blood
oh
this might actually be legit do it in
everything
i forgot which one i had but it was
either impossible or beyond
and i remember eating it and i was like
[ __ ] this tastes like the [ __ ]
hamburgers you get at like school
cafeteria
where'd you go though at at the grocery
store
yeah that's definitely beyond because
impossible just got to grocery stores
like
a week ago but i remember thinking this
is like the crappy hamburgers that uh
school cafeteria served
it's like a mcdonald's yeah i got umami
burger there
whatever one that i have impossible
there that's about it's bomb yeah it's
pretty good i've had that one i get that
there because i'm just like it tastes
good yeah
do you order a regular burger and that
burger so you have a spare in case this
one's nasty you have an amazing
trust that it's going to be good like
because i've been there and i can't do
that i got a bible
it doesn't make you feel all heavy like
a regular burger does that's what's nice
about it yeah it's weird
you you it tastes like a burger it
tastes like a legit burger and you can
cook your medium rare so it literally
has the same banding and like
yeah because of the heme it looks like
yeah so yeah
like if no one told me that that wasn't
beef i wouldn't be able to tell
so my brother-in-law's a chemist and he
like
back years ago they got invited to a
banquet
and the impossible burger people were
sponsoring it
and it was a banquet but they didn't
know that the impossible burger was
sponsoring it and everyone was eating
burgers
and then they pitched this whole thing
and like how they're going to try to
revolutionize the industry with this new
type of burger and like everyone was
kind of doubting it and then
they're like the burgers are eating
today those are impossible burgers
[Music]
you